Okay.
Hey,
what's going on as bill burn?
It's the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
September 1st,
2014 bomp bomp bomp bomp Boda Boda Buddha.
Do Buddhas
eat some fucking shit?
Fat,
tits,
fat.
It's fat.
It's you guys ready?
Huh?
Football season.
Time to stop working out everybody.
The summer is over.
The summer is over time to watch people in way better shape than you making way
more money than you was.
You get fatter and dumber.
I don't know about you guys,
but I can't fucking wait.
Okay.
I'm putting away my little speedo fucking bathing suit for the rest of the
summer.
I am now taking out my football shit,
my jerseys and my stupid fucking hardhat that I put those construction.
You know I don't do construction,
but I have a fucking logo on the side.
Don't you hate that somebody did that back then?
I think the Steeler fans were the first ones to do that and they actually were
building bridges and they actually worked at construction sites.
Then after a while you just kind of look at somebody going like,
is that a foreman?
I don't think has that an account.
I think there's an account is that a fake fucking construction had?
Um,
anyways,
I'm so fucking beyond excited that it's football season.
It's been a while.
It has been awhile since I got this excited and uh,
I watched a little bit of college football.
I did my usual a rooting against.
I don't even know why I root against Alabama.
I don't,
I don't really not like them.
I'm a fucking,
you know,
I'm a guy from Massachusetts.
Where do I get off not liking a,
the Alabama Crimson tide over you fucking say crimson tide.
You know,
I just somehow fell into with Lsu and I missed every second in that game because
I was doing the other wonderful odd ball tour.
But uh,
I,
uh,
I can see went down by 20 something and they came back and won.
So,
um,
that's great that they did that.
But that's not really an impressive way to start,
you know,
against boring ass fucking Wisconsin.
What do they do?
Run the ball to death.
I'm just fucking with you,
Wisconsin.
All right.
I just wanted to get you up off the couch away from that giant fucking cheese
block or whatever the fuck it is she doing.
Okay.
He's sitting there with his and her cargo shorts on.
Um,
car girl,
I can't talk.
Fuck you.
I just got off a plane and I ran home to do this on Labor Day.
Happy Labor Day.
Everybody,
um,
help you fucking,
ob not listening to this right now because that would mean that you're out with
some friends and shit.
Right?
Unless you listened to this later,
at which point,
you know,
maybe he had a falling out,
maybe finally just fucking broke it off with somebody.
And I don't even mean in like a romantic way.
You had a romantic relationship.
How about you just fucking get rid of a friend?
Is there's a great new year's resolution to make in September,
September 1st isn't it the Chinese year,
New Year or something?
The year or the oscillating fan,
whatever the fuck it is.
I don't know.
Um,
that's a great thing to do.
Okay.
Especially after the,
I don't know,
depending on how old you are,
you've had friends for a long fucking time.
This,
this gotta be one of them.
You gotta be like,
you know what?
I'm just sick of your shit.
I'm sick.
You know what?
I'm sick of the ride.
It's the same fucking ride.
And it ends up with an apology as you're pulling into the station up,
dude,
I'm sorry,
but blah,
blah,
blah.
And then when you should get off the ride and you don't,
you stay on and here we go again going up the hill.
But the,
but the do,
everything seems good.
Everything seems good.
And they fucking cross that line again.
All right.
And then you go around the fucking rollercoaster.
That's the big God damn fight.
And then you pull in.
Yeah,
you're right.
I'm sorry.
You know,
I've just been going through some shit lately,
but multiple pit bull and then you're forgiven.
Asked says it's okay and you get back on the fucking right again.
Um,
okay.
Get off the fucking ride.
Is there a talk show about that?
There's all kinds of talk shows about romantic relationships,
but is there anything out there that just talks about,
I guess that court TV is friendships gone wrong,
those stupid TV judges sit there screaming and everybody,
cause they're trying to get you to quit flipping channels.
What is it about watching somebody getting yelled at?
You just have to stop and watch.
I hate those judge shows.
I don't care about the people.
I don't care about their fucking problems and how,
you know,
he took one of the fucking pickets out of my fence so I threw some dog shit over
his fence and then he fucking pissed in my car.
I mean,
I mean they're not even that compelling,
you know,
dumb it down to the level of my act and that's basically what's going on.
And then at some point somebody talks and then the judge has got to start
screaming and yelling.
Yeah,
I hate how they have the actual authority still of a judge.
You know what I mean?
You should.
It should be like optional.
Whether you listened to them at not and I don't give a fuck all you people out
there right now going,
well actually you know judge Wapner was actual judge and all these people.
Actually I don't give a shit.
All right.
The second year on TV,
you're not a judge anymore.
That's like the old timers game for judges.
You know like one of right before the all star game,
right.
They'll have an old rod Carue will come out and all the greats,
you know when they're swinging the bat and they can barely fucking run cause
they're in their sixties as the same thing with these judges.
Once you go on TV,
you're not,
you're not your job anymore,
I don't think.
Unless you're in show business and you were a dancing monkey from your first
fucking open mic.
Like what's his face?
The Guy who looks like a fucking cop from the 1970s Dr Phil,
a crooked cop at that.
Right?
That guy,
he's not a therapist.
He's not a therapist anymore.
He is a fucking TV star with groupies.
Right?
Cocaine if he wants it,
it's not a therapist.
I don't even know what I'm talking about.
I'm not a fuck I got onto this thing.
All I know is it's Labor Labor Day.
Yeah.
Okay.
And I,
and I,
and it's,
this is,
this is the perfect fucking holiday to set off the football season.
You know,
the one day a week,
that one game,
that fucking couch,
they all count cause there's only 16 of them.
So they're all important.
Two game losing streak.
You're,
you're,
you're in trouble.
Right?
Those football players had been working out all God damn summer to get into peak
physical condition.
And what better way to honor them than to sit down and just completely blow out
your fucking body.
That's what I plan on doing.
Okay.
Sick of this fucking working out shit.
Yeah.
I want to fucking,
I want to grill.
That's what I want to do for the whole football season.
I'm gonna fucking grill something different is what I would like to do.
Eat like an angel all fucking week.
Right.
My little button nose.
You know,
my dreamy eyes.
I'm just going to add another compliment to every physical thing that I have.
MMM.
No,
I should say dreamy eyes.
I've got to make it easier for you guys.
My confident forehead.
I don't know what that means.
Um,
anyways.
Okay.
That's what I want to fucking do.
And uh,
I actually have a little bit of time off this year cause
uh,
I just decided to take some fucking time off.
You know,
cause I get the NFL package every year,
but it's usually like today I come flying back from the fucking road.
I already know what happened and I sit down and I can sort of fast forward my
way through the game,
but I don't get to go through all the emotion of it and any of that type of
shit.
So this year,
this fucking year,
I plan on doing it.
Okay.
I plan on doing it so I don't,
I don't really know what's going on in football.
The game I watched,
I watched,
uh,
I watched West Virginia versus Alabama and I really resent the highlights of
that game where they just keep showing Alabama scoring when there wasn't some
major concern going on down there in Tuscaloosa,
ski there.
And I was like tweeted for those of you follow me on Twitter.
Um,
that was a close fucking game and uh,
I didn't see Lsu,
but I imagine I wouldn't have been impressed with them either if they got down
by 20 something and I know they'll fuck they were playing or Wisconsin.
That's why I brought it up.
Um,
but uh,
and I was at me,
but that was sort of supposed to be a cupcake game for Alabama and they,
uh,
I dunno.
Hey,
by the way,
his lane Kiffin uh,
whatever his fucking name is,
is he associated with Alabama?
I wasn't sure the first 58 fucking times they showed that guy what was the big
fucking deal,
you know?
Yeah.
He had a great job at Tennessee,
told them to go fuck themselves.
I'd rather be out here in USC,
you know,
tagging some Hollywood pussy.
Okay.
Then he went to the fucking Raiders and now he's back there.
It gives a shit.
He's a coach.
You hang around long enough,
you're going to get fired or whatever.
Or if you're smart enough,
you leave early.
That's the game I want to see.
I want to see when Alabama
goes up to Tennessee and it's the first time lane Kiffin uh,
has been there since he fucking left.
Now for those of you don't watch college football,
they take it really seriously down there in the south,
especially in the sec.
And by the way,
they've got this great commercial now,
how they swept all the awards,
any fucking major award that you could be.
There could be one last year.
The SEC did it.
That's never been done by any conference and they won the fucking national
title.
So a,
I think they have bragging rights straight across the board and everybody else
has to pipe down.
But uh,
so anyways,
they take the shit real seriously.
So out there in Knoxville,
Tennessee,
for those of you never been there,
it's in the eastern part of the state.
It is on east coast time.
Okay.
If you're thinking about driving from xannies and Nashville to drive over to a
fucking game,
you will lose an hour.
Okay.
And you might miss the beginning of the game,
but you can still drive back and make your show.
All right.
Um,
although I never did it,
it was just going to be too much of a fucking trash.
But that is one of my bucket lists games.
I want to go to that stadium with the Purina Cat Chow,
fucking Ah,
you know,
and zone painted.
And everybody's going like,
dude,
you don't want to go out there.
I know this guy from Tennessee.
Right.
And he fucking said they're animals don't go out there.
And it's just like,
what the fuck's going to happen to me?
I'll put it on a Tennessee hat and I'll just fucking whatever they say,
I'll just say it to,
yeah,
like some guy are,
you fucking know.
You fucking know it.
Give me some of that and then I'll just keep walking in.
Nobody's gonna fuck with me.
I just want to go see it.
So anyways,
lane Kiffin was the head coach at Tennessee.
Tennessee has that sort of up and down.
But I mean,
generally speaking,
as a respected program,
as far as I know,
and what I know of it was,
since,
you know,
Peyton manning was there,
so I don't know shit about it.
So I'm going to talk about it without knowing and all you people in Knoxville
can tell me what a dumped fuck I am.
And I don't give a shit as long as you listen,
as long as you listen.
So anyways,
uh,
so he goes there and he's going to turn the program around,
right?
Yup.
Buckets.
They all sound the same,
right?
Bap,
bap,
bap.
It's all the same fucking song.
Um,
okay.
So anyways,
he's going to go there.
He's going to turn this fucking program around and then all of a sudden USC out
of nowhere,
you know,
he probably gave the big long speech,
going to turn this program around 10,
she's had a long and storied history.
You have a wedding,
a Gi by planned your restore that blah blah blah.
So all these fucking Knoxvillians.
Okay.
They're out there shining up.
They're smokers.
They buy an extra tens of chew,
their crease in the visor on their hat even farther.
They're getting an extra oily rag in their back pocket.
They are fucking in.
They have bought into the lane Kiffin era,
whatever his fucking name.
I'm probably saying it wrong.
I don't give a shit.
Um,
I should probably look it up.
Uh,
lane Kiffin right.
And then out of nowhere
in the middle of the night,
he accepts a fucking job with,
uh,
with USC and he just fucking leave.
And it gets,
that was really embarrassing for everybody in Tennessee because they didn't,
they,
they don't,
they view their school as a destiny school for a coach.
Like they're being head coach of the volunteers should be your dream job.
We have won enough games,
we have done enough things that we should be able to hold that status.
And he treated them like a stepping stone,
you know,
like some bitchy was banging on the side and then his fucking wife called and he
fucking comes running home.
So basically they can't stand this motherfucker.
And um,
so the way I said I wouldn't get in trouble when I went out there,
cause I would just wear a Tennessee hat,
haven't affected accent,
you know,
and they wouldn't give a shit.
They'd be so drunk.
They would notice.
They wouldn't look and be,
why is this German Irish guy talking like he's on?
He,
ah,
it wouldn't register.
They'd be like,
okay,
fucking love this guy,
man.
Look at him
redneck.
He's fucking red head man.
Easy.
And,
but he's in a deeper than we are.
Um,
but lane is going to go back and he can't do that shit.
He's got to come back.
Where in Alabama he's got to where Alabama fucking colors,
you know that team named after the detergent.
I thought that they,
you know,
something if West Virginia had converted on a couple of more plays,
like that fucking game could have gone the other way,
which you can also say about Alabama.
I mean that one poor kid,
he dropped like a 50 yard bomb.
It was right in his hands.
Um,
so I know you can say that,
but uh,
it was way closer than the way that they showed the highlights.
But um,
anyways,
I'm really excited,
uh,
that,
that college football is back and uh,
I'm psyched to watch SCC football.
I fucking love it.
It is the vest and I'm also excited to see other conferences to try to dethrone
them.
Okay,
so that's what happens on Saturday.
On Saturday,
right.
And then on Sunday you got,
you got pro football,
pro football.
This is such a great time of year.
And then you also got baseball.
The Games are starting to matter.
Like I'm actually starting to pay attention to my,
my fucking,
my deep,
my Detroit Tigers,
old Billy bandwagon is the Detroit Tigers Fan.
Why?
Why you ask?
Because I got,
I bought in half on red sox season tickets this year and I lost my fucking
shirt.
I know I live out here,
but it's the fucking red sox.
They just won the world series and I'm thinking,
all right,
whatever.
I don't fucking go to,
I can throw them up on stub hub.
All right.
And someone will buy em and I'll,
I'll at least break even.
But when your team just never gets,
they never got going this whole year.
I don't give a shit out bad.
Your team is at some point they put together a little bit of a streak,
gives the fan base a little bit of hope.
It never fucking happened.
And um
oh shit.
This is Andrew talking about the fucking podcast.
All right,
no worries.
I'm sorry.
I just got a text anyways and they never got going and I've just lost my fucking
shirt.
So last game of the year I have tickets,
it's going to be Derek Jeters last time at Fenway Park.
Now I could sell those two tickets and make some of my money back or I could go
back and pay my fucking respects to one of the best baseball players I ever saw,
both on and off field the whole way conducted ambassador the fucking game.
So you know what I'm going to do?
I'm going to fly back to the game now.
If the Yankees don't make the playoffs,
that is his last game he ever fucking place.
However,
if the Tigers shit the bed,
I think that they got a four and a half game lead cause I got one game,
one game at hand or they play one last game.
I should say one game in hand,
I guess as a gay man,
hand his hockey,
but whatever.
Um,
if they shit the bed than the Yankees,
they get in and then it Kinda,
it's not as big a moment.
So I'm not being in a Yankee hater here.
I just,
I'm being a selfish fan where I want to go to his last game,
ever see his last at bat,
um,
match.
That's some,
that's some legendary shit right there,
you know?
And I always show Ted Williams last at bat at Fenway or whatever.
So this is,
this is probably the biggest last at bat in Fenway.
I'm trying to think of a,
come on.
Why don't you guys who plays in the baseball fantasy leagues?
When are you stat guys?
Who's the other than Ted Williams,
who had the most famous lasted bat.
Okay,
I got me an obviously you'd guess a of big time red sox.
I'd say the next biggest red sock after him would be a,
okay,
Carl Yastrzemski,
unless you want to count Babe Ruth's last fucking at bet before we sold them to
the fucking Yankees.
Oops.
Um,
he's Kinda fat,
you know,
I dunno,
he's drinking all the time.
Look,
we want our three,
whatever.
He's going to go down to the fucking shit hole.
Go down there.
He fucking dig to the Yankees.
They share a stadium.
Dude,
you realize that you,
before babe Ruth came there,
the Yankees,
like the jets,
you know where the jets played at giant stadium.
The Yankees played at the Polo grounds,
which was the giant stadium.
And then Babe Ruth comes down there.
All right.
And in next thing,
that's why they call it the House that Ruth built is far as I know.
As far as the drunk people that I've been talking to in sports bar,
I bought sports bars.
I think that that's how the,
that's how the story goes.
Um,
so anyways,
there you go.
There's you,
there's your fucking sports talk for the week.
All right,
now let's get to,
uh,
let's get the paint for the downstairs here.
A dollar shave club.
Everybody,
uh,
nothing feels better than that first shave with a fresh blade,
right?
Nobody can argue that it's smooth.
It's close in.
The blade is as sharp as it's ever going to be.
It's absolutely fantastic.
But thanks to big companies,
big shaving company's ridiculous prices.
You can't really afford to be blowing all your cash every week on fresh new
blades canyon.
So what do you do?
You try to economize and you drag that Dell last blade across your face for two
weeks,
three weeks,
10 weeks.
You know,
digging up your face.
Why are you doing that to yourself?
Maybe because the only thing more painful than shaving with an old blade is
shelling out 30 bucks for a pack and new ones.
If you want to enjoy a fresh blade every week,
but you don't want to get a take out a second mortgage on your house,
you got to join dollar shave club.com for just a couple of bucks a month.
Dollar Shave club.com ships you the highest quality blades you can get.
I'm serious.
The only six bucks for the best quality blades you can get.
So every week you can pop in a fresh blade and treat yourself to an amazing
shave.
That awful feeling a dragon,
that old razor.
It's,
it's out the window.
It's incredible.
This should have happened years ago.
God bless these bastards over here@dollarshaveclub.com for coming up with this.
Uh,
you can join dollar shave club.com.
Get amazing quality blades in the mail for just a couple of bucks a week and a
treat yourself to a new blade every single week.
Hundreds of thousands of guys have upgraded their shaving with dollar shave
club.com and now what is your term?
You're now it is your turn.
Sorry.
Shave time.
Shave money,
dollar shave club.com/.
Bird.
That's dollar shave club.com/.
Bar.
Do you know how bad I wish they had that one?
I was just a youngster.
I used to do that exact thing.
I would make a pack of blades laugh last for like a year and a half
fucking neck.
All broken out.
All right.
stamps.com everybody.
I know it's tough deciding where to focus your resources to grow your business.
But one thing I can't tell you,
you don't need to waste valuable time going through the post office or mailing
and shipping.
Just use stamps.com to access all the services of the post office right from
your desk 24 seven with stamps.com you can buy and print official us postage
using your own computer and your printer.
Get postage for any letter or package,
any class of mail,
all for just a fraction of the cost of an expensive postage meter with
stamps.com you'll never have to go to the post office again so you can spend
your time where it matters most.
Focusing on your business.
I use stamps.com to send out my posters,
my DVDs,
my tee shirts,
whatever crap I'm selling at the end of my shows.
I am a moron if I can figure out how to use the scale on the computer and all of
that crap.
So can you,
um,
right now he's my last name burpee.
You rr for this special offer,
no risk trial plus a $110 bonus offer that includes a digital scale and up to
$55 free postage.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of the homepage and type in [inaudible].
B.
U.
R.
Okay.
We'll get to the other ones later.
Just set this thing up here.
Um,
all right,
let's talk more about,
so this weekend I had such a great time.
I did the,
uh,
the odd ball tour.
Remember that the odd ball slash pay for Billy's basement here.
Um,
it was just a great time,
man.
Anytime,
uh,
you know,
I don't get to see those guys.
Everybody that I toured with and uh,
you know,
we went out,
we had drinks,
I don't even remember where the fuck we were.
There was somewhere in Michigan.
They booked us at these amp he theaters,
so like,
you know,
the gigantic,
so they need gigantic parking lot so that they're not really in major cities.
So,
um,
I landed in Detroit and uh,
I fucking love that city man.
I really love that.
See,
I swear to God,
okay,
I want to find a couple of investors and I just want to buy a block.
You know,
just buy a block of it.
You redo it.
You just make it some late night shit.
Couple of clubs.
Not now,
but you need a grocery store to make people move in.
Okay.
That's what I,
that's why I,
for years when I looked at Cleveland and I looked at,
uh,
Detroit,
buffalo is not as bad,
but even like buffalo,
you just look,
it's like all it's going to take it,
just do these fucking buildings.
They're beautiful.
I Dunno.
But every time I get there it gets a little bit better.
So every time I go to Detroit's a little bit better,
Cleveland's like fucking does all kinds of building going on there,
man.
I like all of those.
I like all of those,
um,
cities a lot.
Like I don't know what it is.
I don't know if because my family's from the Midwest and we drove out there a
few times,
but there's something about the Midwest.
I really like it.
And um,
so anyways,
we performed down there,
um,
wherever the fuck we were at.
I don't even know.
I can't,
I can't tell you the name of one venue.
They were all like the,
you know,
named after some cell phone company.
Um,
but the,
the crowds were just amazing.
Absolutely amazing the whole weekend.
And I really got to see a,
you know,
just working with,
some of the best comics in the country,
some of the best up coming guys.
Some of those ones that are going to be the guys,
you know.
Um,
we all went out drinking.
Dude,
I fucking went out drinking and Detroit.
Well that's where we stayed at the MGM,
now it's coming back to me and I was riding back in the van
with Naper gutsy and he got wind of like saying,
hearing that I said on my podcast that Golf wasn't a sport and do the whole way
back into the bar through the second round of drinks.
We argued about whether or not it was a sport or not.
And he,
he brought up Nascar.
He said,
those guys are athletes.
I'm like,
dude,
I'm not saying that somebody who drives a NASCAR,
a NASCAR vehicle is not an athlete,
but you don't have to be,
you don't have to be a fuck any sport.
Like I said,
any sport where you can throw like a girl,
then it's not a fucking,
it's just,
you know,
if you don't have hand icore and somebody throws you a ball and you fucking
tense up and it bounces off you like they just throw it against the wall.
I know guys like that and that there's still good drivers.
I'm not saying that they're NASCAR level,
but to me,
okay.
As much as it's an insult,
I'm going to get myself in trouble again here.
As much as it's an insult to golf,
a lot of people would say that.
I say it's not a sport.
I think it's an insult to Nascar to just say it's a sport
cause like the NASA level shit that is going on in pit row.
That's the funniest thing about going to a race
okay.
Is if you're,
if you're in the stance right across from pit row,
the level of intellect that's across the track,
trying to figure out basically how to make these rockets that don't leave the
ground go like fucking 10th of a mile faster than somebody else.
And you're talking,
they're going like 100 8,200 miles an hour or whatever the fuck they do now with
the restrictive plates.
And if you go right across the track,
it's guys like me lag.
There was a cooler eaten Bologna fucking sandwiches.
I Dunno.
I,
I think I actually,
I'm not,
I'm not shitting on Nascar.
G I think it's a fucking insult to say that it's a sport.
Okay.
Um,
I,
I don't think so.
All right.
And also the fact
of where it came from that it basically came out of like bootlegging during
prohibition and having like a stock car.
You look at a car and you think it's just stock from the factory,
but he got under the hood,
you know,
I love that shit.
That's why I was talking last week.
I love that Mercedes Benz station wagon,
but it comes to the AMG factory.
So and go,
you know,
whatever,
it's zero to 60 in 3.5 seconds.
But people think you're,
you know,
you're going to the grocery store.
I love a fucking sweet.
So,
um,
I'm not disrespecting Nascar by saying that it's not a sport,
I just look at it.
I think that's an insult to,
to racing to say that it's a sport.
You know,
cause as great as basketball is,
at the end of the day,
you're putting a ball through a hoop.
All right?
Is Great as hockey as you're trying to put a fucking rubber disk into a net and
you can do that with all them.
The four major sports,
what they're doing.
Okay.
Is,
is an entirely different level.
Like they're changing what's possible
in,
in transportation.
Like I don't even know how to say it.
I'm too dumb to say talking to like all the,
like the amount of like physics,
the technology that is going on,
I dunno,
I would say it's closer to transformers than it is a sport,
but whatever.
So Nate is just sitting there like
flipping out.
And he and his argument about golf is what everybody says about how fucking hard
it is.
And I just keep going like,
dude,
just because it's hard doesn't mean it's a sport.
Algebra two and trig was really hard for me.
I didn't think it was a sport.
I also don't think just because there's a fucking ball,
it makes it a sport either.
All right.
So whatever.
I'm going to have Nate,
I'm going to have Nate pour gutsy on my podcast because it was such a fucking
long argument.
And then we got into the whole Nascar thing.
I'm going to have him on here and plus you guys should know about him because
he's a fucking phenomenal comedian.
Um,
really one of my favorites that's coming up.
I worked,
yeah,
just a lot of really funny guys.
Hannibal Burress,
that whole fucking generation of guys,
Michael Che,
all of those guys are fucking hilarious.
And um,
the next night we went to Pittsburgh.
Yeah.
And uh,
Pittsburgh is one of my favorite cities out there.
MMM.
It just sucks down when I go there.
I'm only there for one night.
So I think next next year is I'm putting together my fucking hour.
I might do a little three,
four day run.
There is always something,
you know what I've always wanted to do.
They always wanted to take that fucking whatever the hell it is that tram up
that hill that you see.
Every time I go there,
I look out my hotel window.
I'm like,
this is that God damn thing.
I always say I'm going to go up there.
Okay.
Was fucking Illuminati houses looking down on the city.
Like we,
we run shit.
Like they have the power switch switch up there and they're going to flip it
whenever they want to have people get out of line and shut everything off.
MMM.
And then the last one we did,
we did outside of a Chicago should another fucking unbelievable city then I
don't never get to spend enough time.
And um,
another great show.
And on that one we had Amy
hello.
And she fucking crushed,
fucking crushed.
And uh,
yeah,
I got to work with Sarah Silverman.
I never get to work with her.
MMM.
Chris Delea and ever get to work with him.
I just,
it was just fucking awesome.
And you know,
had a fucking going up to Jim Jefferies every night,
which is Jesus Christ,
fucking guys,
one of the best storytellers I've ever heard.
And I'm thinking,
all right,
I'm going to get a night off because there's a buffer between fucking him and
me.
And then fucking Amy Schumer goes out and absolutely destroyed.
But it was a,
it was a great time.
Uh,
the crowds were so well behaved.
That was,
it was fucking awesome.
And then,
uh,
and then the end of the night,
I got to hang out with all these comics.
Uh,
it's one of the reasons why I like doing comedy festivals cause you get to hang
with the other comments and stuff.
Chris Hardwick,
another guy I worked with,
I'm trying to remember to say everybody.
Oh,
and what's his face?
Uh,
Steven Brody Stevens is the funniest fucking host ever.
He says so much shit.
The crowd doesn't even get in the comics in the back of fucking diet.
He said,
what the fuck did he say?
He was going,
I can't,
I'm going to do a bad impression of him.
And He's got ladies and gentlemen,
the level of comedian you are going to see tonight,
these Comedians,
I've been on television,
they'd been blah,
blah,
blah.
He goes,
these comedians own houses.
I know,
I fucking butchered it,
but the crowd doesn't even get it because they're sitting in the crowd is like,
well,
we own houses.
They don't understand that most comics,
it sucks if you stick with,
you don't end up with a house.
Okay.
Oh,
you stay in a one bedroom apartment.
I look at me,
I fucking,
I bought a house when I was 43 years old.
I finally got a house and before then I was,
you know,
okay.
In a one bedroom apartment,
you just terminally in this one bedroom apartment waiting for this big break.
So it was a really inside fucking joke and it,
uh,
I butchered it.
Whatever.
I,
um,
like we got a great picture that,
uh,
I dunno who the fuck took it.
I can't even remember.
I was drinking so much this weekend,
but uh,
mmm.
Steven Brody Stevens used to play a AAA baseball or something,
a college level baseball.
And you know,
that warm up thing that they do when they walk across the field and they're
kicking their foot up into the air and they're trying to touch their hands.
It's above his head.
He brought up crystal Leah,
and when he was walking offstage,
he was doing that.
Yeah.
And I never addressed it.
Never looked at the crowd.
Somebody took a picture.
It's one of the coolest fucking pictures I've seen.
I'll,
I'll retweet it on the,
uh,
the [inaudible] podcast at the m and podcasts Twitter thing.
But,
um,
but whatever,
man,
it was a,
it was a great,
great time.
And I'm
okay.
You know,
I don't like where my fucking act is.
Uh,
currently.
And evidently a few people in the crowd didn't either.
Uh,
we can grow it back in the van last night.
It was fucking hilarious.
And we just,
we,
all we were doing was reading the tweets from people that didn't us in the van
ride back was one of the funniest van rides.
I had somebody write a bill burr is killing dot,
dot,
dot.
My Buzz.
Uh,
and then it said,
please get off the stage Hashtag bull
and another guy,
right?
Uh,
he tried to claim that I,
I told the crowd to go out and murder people if fucking I laughed so hard when I
read that.
It's just like,
what is so funny about doing standup is,
or just public speaking in general is the second you get done saying it,
it's,
it's not yours anymore.
It goes into people's heads.
I've know I've said this before,
but however they here it is how they hear it,
and then they write back to you with supreme confidence that they totally
understood your intentions.
This guy said that I was on stage and I told the crowd that go out and go murder
people.
I didn't say that.
That completely wasn't my point.
Um,
but I've learned to not,
I've tried to anyways learn to not give a shit and just be like,
all right,
well that just has to do with maybe somebody yelled right as I said that
sentence and he didn't hear it.
Or maybe it's his childhood.
I don't know what,
but he wrote like,
you know,
cause I was retweeting people said Nice things like,
hey,
you really made me laugh.
I retweeted that and he wrote to me like,
you know,
hey bill,
retweet this.
Maybe like,
you know,
hands on the hips,
with the fifth st and then like Superman,
like so fucking confident.
I actually had to think for half a second to be like,
what fucking joke that I tell that he thought that that's what I was saying.
I was like,
Oh,
I know what joke it is.
Yeah.
It's like,
dude,
I want,
and I wanted to write back to them like,
you know,
or you could
okay,
you know,
pay a little closer attention to the meeting of the joke,
but maybe he was paying attention.
That's just how we heard it.
But you know what,
that's not my fault.
It's not my fault that you,
that that's what you heard.
I find that a little bizarre that that's what you thought.
Um,
I hope that whoever wrote that isn't one of those,
uh,
one of those list people and all those people that are just kind of like,
they got their little list like,
okay,
these,
these are good words.
These are bad words,
you know,
or not,
not even like bad,
just like there's one context.
Like if you say this word,
that means you're a homophobe.
If you say this word,
that means you're sexist.
If you,
if you feel this way on this subject,
a,
you're a Jesus freak,
you're a gun nut.
Uh,
you're,
you're a baby murderer or whatever the,
wherever they stand on whatever fucking issue,
abortion,
whatever.
Like they don't listen to what you're saying.
Um,
and it,
what it makes for some really entertaining tweets.
MMM.
I had to save him.
I had to save him one time and just fucking,
I'd say put out a book,
but why do that?
No one would do one on one would buy it.
Just fucking,
you know,
save the Goddamn tree with this laptop that probably killed fucking 40,000 trees
and I'll just put them all out there.
I got somewhere in my,
one of my hard drives,
I have a bunch of hate mail.
I just kept saving them because they were fucking hilarious.
And I was also trying to learn to see the humor in them perse back in the day
would actually write the people back and then what you learn after a while it's
just like,
ah,
you know,
you actually kind of a wait like validated,
what they said is wrong,
then just let it go.
You know?
It's kind of what I've learned.
Just let it fucking disappear into the abyss.
But I got to tell you,
they're fucking hilarious to read.
Hashtag bu um,
anyways,
where are we?
Where are we in the podcast at this point?
36 minutes in.
All right.
I'm going to go a little short because it's also my Labor Day,
you know?
Yeah.
It worked so fucking hard.
Don't tell him jokes.
Goddamn fucking,
what the hell is this Labor Day?
I think I read this every year because I always forget what it is.
A Labor Day in the United States,
few people around the world,
um,
is a holiday celebrated on the first Monday in September.
You know,
I realized there's actually somebody who might work in a sweatshop listening to
this going like beside themselves,
you know,
going like,
you actually have the balls to have a labor day after.
What the fuck I do.
You know?
Or maybe they used to work there because if you still work,
they probably wouldn't have a laptop.
You know,
they don't allow you to see things.
Do they,
have you guys seen that movie about that train that never stops moving with Ed
Harris?
Not Jesus.
Did I just ruin the end of the movie?
I'm going to shut up right now.
I think I just ruined the end of the movie.
Um,
Labor Day in the United States.
Everybody has a holiday,
several celebrated on the first Monday in September.
It is a celebration of the American labor movement and is dedicated to the
social and economic achievements of workers.
Basically,
they had slave labor here and we started unions to get out of it.
And then,
uh,
the unions for the most part became what they were fighting and then the
companies left.
And uh,
now we're all in cubicles.
Uh,
it constitutes a yearly national tribute to the contribution of workers have
made to the strength,
prosperity and the wellbeing of their country.
Uh,
well that's what it is.
Sorry.
Labor Day was from promoted by the Central Labor Union and the Knights of Labor
who organized the first parade in New York City and the Hay market massacre,
which occurred in Chicago on May 4th,
1886 law.
Oh,
well I got,
we got to look over this one.
This is why you get a decent wage cause I,
these people died.
It's fucking unbelievable protest and how much you make an hour and you actually
take a shovel to the fucking head.
The Haymarket affair also known as the Hay affair,
also known as the Hay market massacre.
This is like,
you know,
whether which side of the shovel you are on,
if you were the one who killed somebody or was sent the people down to kill the
fucking rabble rousers,
it was called the,
the,
the Haymarket affair.
And everybody who was there or a new people got killed called it the massacre.
Okay.
And the cops called it the Haymarket riot.
All right,
here we go.
What's the aftermath of a bombing that took place at a labor demonstration on
Tuesday the fourth,
1886 at Haymarket square in Chicago.
It began as a peaceful rally and support of the workers striking,
uh,
for an eight hour day and in reaction to the killing of several workers by the
police,
uh,
the previous day.
Oh,
that was the shovel day.
Alright.
And unknown and unknown person through a dynamite bomb at the police as they
acted to disperse that,
that's not the way you get your point.
Heard the bomb blast.
Oh wait,
am I have this backwards?
Maybe the workers called it the affair.
Oh,
that f Dota was alive.
We had a little affair,
you know,
I was doing,
I was one fucking Steptoe one stick,
whatever dude,
they should be on our side.
So then I would say that the,
the cops called it the massacre and also see that this is the great thing about
me is I don't read and I just form a fucking opinion and then I weighed into the
swamp.
I don't think it's that deep harden hall.
Um,
the bomb blast in the ensuing gunfire resulted in the deaths of seven police
officers in,
at least for civilian scores of others were wounded.
Yeah.
That's not a good time to get wounded either in 1886.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
Um,
so anyways,
yeah.
So who knows that and now it's just this day that we sit around and we take a
day off and you listen to some fucking moron do a podcast.
Um,
all right.
Anyways,
let's get to the,
uh,
to the wonderful questions this week.
Oh Shit.
Here we go.
I actually have a,
um,
a big promotion here for a good friend of mine,
Joe De Rosa,
also known as the teen idols.
Sensation from the Opium Anthony Program,
a k a Joey Roses Aka roses,
Aka Joey D,
um,
Aka shoulder list.
Joe.
All right,
Joe to Rosa has a new album coming out digitally on Tuesday,
September 2nd.
That is tomorrow.
If you're listening to it on September 1st or it's yesterday,
it listen to it on Wednesday the third,
or it was seven years ago and you finally discovered me.
How are you in the future?
My still alive,
um,
on Tuesday,
September 2nd,
and it's called mistakes were made.
This is actually a really cool idea,
Eh,
uh,
mistakes were made the,
besides,
it's a double disk of unreleased material recorded at various places over the
last seven years.
It's essentially Joe's version rarities that a band would put out.
Uh,
I think that's cool as hell.
And I'll tell you right now,
I,
for one,
I know what I'm doing tomorrow,
September 2nd,
downloading that album.
Then congratulating my good buddy Joe to Rosa for a job well done.
All right,
leaked photos.
Billy gatekeeper,
the Internet almost exploded Sunday because a massive dump of hacked nude
pictures of celebrities.
Yes,
it is a violation of trust.
it would be a moral to post or spread.
But my question to you is what if you were the nine to five or even worse night
shift guy that doesn't have a lot going on.
No girlfriend,
no future.
How was it?
How was not looking at them making the world better or preventing it from being
an issue?
So let's break this down.
Millions of us see Jennifer Lawrence nude,
but guy with nine to five dozen.
Yeah.
Does that change anything?
I don't understand your question here.
Millions of people.
All this saying,
I guess I missed on the out in the store.
So I guess they were leaked.
Millions of people saw them and now they're saying out of respect for her,
you don't look at him.
So the guy with the nine to five just hears about it.
Should he not look at it?
MMM.
Does it change anything?
Well,
it'd be nice if people respect people's privacy.
I mean that.
Okay,
you got to understand that.
All of us by being on the Internet,
you got a tiger by the tail.
And,
um,
I never liked that cloud thing.
I always thought it was,
I didn't like that they had my photos.
Even if they don't leak,
somebody has it and somebody could look at them.
You know,
it's like,
you mean not like I'm taking pictures my dick or something.
I mean,
I don't know why I would do that.
That's fucking weird.
Um,
but it's just,
you know,
family photos and just private photos of where I am and what I'm doing.
Like all of that type of stuff.
Yeah,
I think that's really weird.
And um,
I dunno,
I don't like any of this shit.
I don't like doing any of,
this is why I don't bank online.
Even though I know all my information,
my,
all my,
if my information is online,
just in case they want to bank online,
which is fucking hilarious to me.
I don't think that that should be legal.
I think they should have had to clear that with me because anything that is
online is compromised.
There is no such thing as a secure site.
All there is is more secure.
So,
um,
okay.
I Dunno,
I would like to think that you wouldn't do it.
I'm not going to do it.
She's mortified.
She,
this plenty of naked women out there on the Internet that are doing it and
making money off of it and want to do it.
Just respect your privacy and don't do it.
You wouldn't want somebody doing that to you.
Um,
okay.
Not that anybody give a fuck senior naked,
but whatever that,
that version of it is,
you wouldn't want somebody to hack into your bank account,
take all your money in that of Shit,
you know?
Um,
I feel bad for,
I uh,
you know,
but I mean,
hopefully everybody stops using the cloud.
I think I actually,
inadvertently,
I'm using,
I'm on the cloud now.
I see that little icon and I don't ever remember signing up for it.
Granted,
I suck at these things,
but,
uh,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
It's,
it's very strange and I just think the further we go into the future,
the less and less privacy's there's going to be an rather than people thinking
about it in a rational way and a human way.
It's just going to be a bunch of screaming and yelling.
Um,
which kind of seems to be what all debate is now.
It's screaming and yelling.
It's not listening to an a another person's point of view.
Having an ability to be swayed,
trying to hear where they're coming from.
It's all about just getting out your point of view,
talking over somebody and hyping you're fucking way,
you know,
it's splitscreen shit where you know they're going to debate something and then
the two people just start yelling at each other and whoever yelled louder I
guess wins.
I Dunno.
It's kind of like those fucking Google glasses.
Like if those things ever take off
the fact that someone can then walk around and just be randomly filming people
and Converse.
Like all privacy is gone.
And I know even though you're out in public,
but you know,
you know at your,
you're,
you should just be interacting with who you're interacting with,
you know,
right then and there like to then take it to annoy you were in public.
So now when I share it with the world,
that's,
I dunno,
I,
I am not looking forward to that aspect of uh,
of the future.
You know what I mean?
I did that.
That,
that shit to me is all fucking creepy.
All right,
so here we go.
Next one.
Dollar bills.
Dear dollar bills.
What's your favorite form of currency?
I'm a huge fan of 20s.
What bill best represents you?
Ah,
man,
dude,
I like the hundred dollar bill.
Not a dollar bills.
The fucking nothing by and you see all Ben's fucking face.
You got a couple of those in your wallet.
That's my favorite.
I liked that.
And I like the five.
I like the five bucks.
Okay.
I like Lincoln.
I just liked the way it looks.
I've always liked the Lincoln memorial.
Um,
the 50s weird.
I really like a a,
I liked the a hundred dollar bill and I'm fascinated with the $500 bill and the
thousand dollar bill.
Like where can you get those?
Can I go down to the bank and withdraw 1000 bucks and say,
yeah,
can I get that?
And I just get $1,000 bill.
That's what I want.
I'm sorry sir.
We don't have any,
well that's how I want it.
Okay,
but then what happens?
Do they have to go get it?
You know,
like you,
you like this.
Well this is like,
it's a special order,
a car and I got to wait three months for the factory to build it.
Like how does that work?
Who uses thousand dollar bills?
Okay,
that's gotta be done.
Like when we're doing some dirty deal arms for hostages,
you know,
you've got that fucking briefcase.
There has to be a bunch of thousand dollar bills in there.
You know what I mean?
I Dunno,
but I would say I like the hundred.
You have a hundred dollar bill,
you feel it.
You just,
you just,
you just become more generous than I got it.
I got it.
You fucking take it out.
You Slam it down on a table.
$20 bill.
You play it a little closer to the chest.
You know,
I only got 20 of these things.
I got a hundred
okay.
Oh,
once a pathetic skates.
All right.
Comedy tour.
Billy.
The king looks like a,
you're having fun on the odd ball tour.
I had a great time.
Could not,
I had a better time.
Please tell us a funny story or a joke from the tour.
I think I already did that.
We saw you wheeling Sarah in the Chris Delea picture on Twitter.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I'll,
I'll retweet that one on the,
uh,
the m podcast too.
I don't even know how that happened.
She was just sick of walking through that giant airport,
so she was trying to like,
you know,
she's making us laugh.
She was trying to almost like treat it like how you'd lay down on a skateboard.
She had this giant bag that she was a checked bag,
so she started going on it.
Then she was slowing down.
I just sort of grabbed it,
started walking with it.
She was like,
this is the fucking greatest way to go through an airport.
She loved it and then Chris Delea took a picture of us and even though we were
having a lot of fun,
what's funny about the picture,
we will laugh and was it looks like we were a couple that just got a rain for
something shady and now we're walking out of court and we're just trying to get
past the press.
Like you know that face people have what they,
when after they get a rain for severe haven't been acquitted.
They haven't been,
they haven't been convicted.
They just got a rain.
Like this is what we are accusing you of and this is the time you are facing
that fucking look.
Um,
I could never have that look on my face and he caught me between emotions.
I think my train of thought was like,
am I going to be in this picture?
I don't think I'm in this picture.
Hey,
go.
Is that funny enough?
I Dunno.
Made me laugh.
He said,
if you are going to put together a comedy tour of only deceased comics and you
are the host,
who would you pick?
Keep in mind,
you have chaplain up there to lean into the wind or Abbott and Costello.
Costello for some who's on first?
Shit.
Legendary bit.
Uh,
they're all dead.
So you're not pissing anyone off.
Um,
all right.
What,
I'm not going to talk about any of my dead friends cause that's too fucking sad.
So I will talk about a Charlie Chaplin to do a standup show.
Yeah,
I'd still have them coming out.
I don't know.
I become a huge fan.
He has,
I like,
I never had the patience to sit down and one of his movies and I was in,
uh,
one was in Montreal.
I sat down and I had breakfast by myself,
sat up at the bar and a Jesus bill.
Even at breakfast,
you were at a bar.
Absolutely.
Um,
and they had it on,
in the background and because it's silent,
you know,
I didn't have to listen to any dialogue and I was actually able to follow it.
And I really got into the whole character of the tramp.
What a piece of shit he was.
And he was always having problems with the cops and running into shady
characters.
He's always going up and down the alleys and stuff.
I,
I just like,
I like this guy,
you know,
so yeah,
I'd have him on the,
I had buster Keaton got,
have WC fields at some point.
My Chicken d him coming out there being all grumpy and shit.
Um,
all the other obvious ones that you've know,
prior,
Carlin,
Kennison,
Hicks,
all of those guys.
Um,
yeah,
I guess I,
you know,
I guess the obvious ones.
Red Fox.
Yeah.
Oh,
speaking of which,
um,
by the way,
uh,
yeah.
Sucks about Joan Rivers right now.
Man.
She doesn't get a fucking,
do you watch,
it's unfortunate if she actually passes away,
which I hope doesn't happen,
there's no way to not put her top five,
top six all fucking time.
If for some reason,
you know,
she hasn't gotten her credit,
I don't understand why.
And for the love of fucking Christ.
I don't want to listen to the fucking woman issue again is plenty of people that
don't get their fucking do.
But I'm sure what's her because it was way back in the day.
I'm sure there was an element of that,
but I'm fucking exhausted what they fucking topic.
Um,
but anyways,
yes.
She's like top fucking,
yeah.
Six,
seven all times five.
Like where if you put her in top five all time abso-fucking-lutely absolutely
like it.
I think cause she still like,
she doesn't put out special,
she's just on that fucking fashion channel shitting on people's dresses.
But if you actually put it on and you listen to the jokes that she's doing,
it's just like that.
If fucking unbelievable.
Who's telling me a joke?
Yeah.
I think Sarah told me this weekend she had a joke.
It was a joke about woody Allen.
Okay.
It was something about somebody,
what I'm going to fuck the whole joke up.
It was something about it.
You know where you're going to be take karate and you're a yellow belt.
Okay.
And she did some sort of joke about
the last time something yellow became came in between woody and whatever that
Mia Farrow,
it was a reference to the karate belt and that he's has an Asian wife.
I completely butchered at Jesus Christ.
I didn't even back into that joke.
I just fucking
threw that thing to the chipper.
Um,
but it's just nice,
the type of Shit I can never get away with that fucking joke.
Um,
so anyways,
I dunno.
I I
I really hope she fucking pulse through man.
Okay.
It's a fucking legend and a half and a all you guys want to be tough on Twitter
and be like,
whoa.
It was a big dude.
You flow Iti would like,
I get it.
You're edgy.
All right.
Back to school.
Hello,
Mr. Barr.
I'm bout to start,
start my sophomore year of high school soon and I want to know if you can give
me some advice.
Yeah,
don't do what I did.
Uh,
I said my grades were pretty good last year,
so that really isn't a problem,
dude.
That's fucking huge.
Keep your grades up,
keep your options wide open.
Unlike mine,
that fucking closed immediately,
uh,
for this upcoming year.
Uh,
also the,
uh,
so the,
the whatever the grades aren't a problem for this upcoming year,
but the girls at my school are,
I have no problem making friends in both genders,
but I can't really seal the deal with the ladies.
I know I am young and probably shouldn't not be worrying about sex yet,
but his horn,
but as a horny teenager,
oh,
Jesus Christ,
please send me,
this is a guy.
He said,
I feel the need.
Oh,
he said with women,
but you know,
you never know.
I said,
I feel the need to at least try and get laid.
I can't seem to be taken seriously by girls in my school.
They seem to think I'm just a comedian and not a possible sexual partner.
Any advice on how to get with these girls?
Any advice is appreciated.
I know you get a lot of advice questions,
so thank you very much for reading this up.
God dammit.
He went respectful.
I love you stand your podcast and you fill in blah,
blah blah and heat breaking bad.
Thank you.
I appreciate all that.
Um,
I didn't get laid in high school,
so I,
you're asking,
you're barking up the wrong fucking tree.
I was,
I was you,
I was you.
I was making my friends laugh,
but I didn't have,
I didn't have women friends either.
So you're,
you're further along than I am.
So I actually meant to ask you,
how did you do that?
Yeah,
I wasn't even like,
oh dude,
it was a fucking barren wasteland.
My,
my,
my childhood was overloaded.
Testosterone,
so overloaded that like,
I don't even like,
you know,
I am just getting like my views and understanding on women it 46,
like I should have been plowing through this at like 19.
MMM.
I it just as far as understanding how,
where they're coming from.
So,
uh,
what,
what can,
what advice can I give you?
Um,
um,
stop being friends with,
with women seek bad advice.
Like I wouldn't do that.
Does.
There's that.
There's that whole fucking bit Chris Rock did where if you stay friends with
them too long,
they view the value of that way.
And then looking at you as a sexual partner becomes gross.
Um,
so what I,
this deal,
I'm not going to go negative.
Stay friends with the women you're friends with.
All right?
But don't become friends with any other ones.
Hit on all the other ones.
All right?
If you're right,
if you're in a really small fucking pawn,
go to a fucking party,
the next town over and be the mysterious guy from the other town.
Although if there's football players,
say they might beat the shit out of you.
At least that's what would happen when I was a kid.
So watch out for that shit.
Um,
I dunno.
I would say the upside is that college is only two years away.
College is only two years away.
And this is the deal.
You're going to be thinking back all the fucking women that you could have
fucking been having fun with.
Uh,
so you just get,
you gotta put it out there,
man.
I think that that's what you're doing.
I think you're being like a,
you,
you don't know how to fucking get into that traffic pattern.
You know,
you just sort of circling the fucking,
you're in a holding pattern here,
man.
You gotta you gotta try to come in for a landing and uh,
I would say any girl that you were friends with,
it's fucking over.
Okay.
Don't even try to hook up with them.
Don't wear them out.
All right.
I would actually,
you know what?
I would do a couple of them.
I would talk to them.
Okay.
He didn't know what,
if you're friends with them,
they'll try and hook you up with some other girl who they'll see is like,
well,
you know,
she wants to meet a boy.
That's dare you go.
That might be the way to get in there.
Hey Nia,
can you help this kid get laid?
This is beyond,
this is beyond my realm.
It's,
it's a,
it's a fucking,
it's,
it gets a kid in high school.
Some kid in high school,
he has no problem making friends.
He's doing well in school.
He has a lot of female friends,
but he can't seem to get past that.
So he's asking me how does he get lays a sophomore in high school.
I was like,
I didn't get sophomore in high school or whatever.
Whole Hook Up,
you know,
get them in the game.
He wants some at bats.
All right,
cute.
He doesn't need to,
he doesn't want to be cute.
This guy wants to be a bad ass man.
He's got marvel man here.
You got to build this dude up.
So,
so he,
he's friends with a lot of women's.
So mummy like a moron.
You know what I said?
It's at first he got to do,
don't be friends with any more women and I immediately heard your voice in my
head going,
you're such a fucking moron.
So I was like,
all right,
scratch that.
So I came up with,
okay,
don't try to hook up with any of the girls you're friends with because they,
they've already stopped looking at you like you're a sexual being.
It's going to see in grocery.
In the friend zone.
Yeah,
the Chris Rock,
Chris Rock Classic Chris Rock.
The friend zone.
So I said,
okay.
A couple of them that you feel like you can trust,
just kind of put it out there like,
hey,
you know,
I go a girls just the plate,
uh,
you back away.
Like,
Eh,
you know,
girls,
they don't want to hook up with me.
They,
Oh gee,
they just look at me like I'm just funny.
And then there'll be like,
what are you talking about?
You have a lot to offer.
And then I think that they'll maybe hook him up with some other girl that they
know that it's probably maybe saying the same shit.
Yeah.
But he probably knows all those girls now.
I feel like he's got to move outside his circle of,
of uh,
the girls that he's friends with.
I mean,
if he wants to sort of be like,
do you guys think,
um,
I don't know,
do some sort of like,
I don't know what I buy cool.
And my leg.
Do you think girls want to like date me?
Because I just feel like,
you know,
can't say,
uh,
my cool.
Once you say saying my cool,
you're not cool anymore.
Well I suggest to Tara,
I suggested that he go to another town,
but I'm worried he's going to run into town.
Yeah,
it'd be the mysterious guy.
Where are you from?
Ah,
the next town over seven 11 baby.
There is a girl that he likes.
He said just go up and just start talking to her,
but just make it clear.
Not by being like,
I want to date you are,
I want to fuck you because I'm looking to get lit.
Not like that,
but just like,
oh this is bad.
Just,
yeah,
just start like,
you know,
just being funny and,
and all that kind of stuff and just being cool with her.
But definitely like you got to put up the flirtatious vibe.
That's what it is.
It's all about properly flirting,
you know what I mean?
And not like lingering too long with it and not like,
oh,
can I,
you know,
just showing up at her locker in between classes already.
They're like,
hey,
so going in Algebra,
Huh?
Like not like that lingering sped.
I learned that the hard way where you linger and I was quiet so I looked like a
psycho.
Creepy.
Yeah,
definitely.
I could definitely see that being your,
uh,
your thing.
Oh,
when I was younger,
my thing like I'm a fucking creep.
I didn't know what to do.
I was all,
I was all Billy freckles.
I,
it wasn't,
it was a man without a country.
Just flirt with them.
Just be cute with them.
Give them a compliment.
Don't go too overboard with it.
You know,
even if it's just something like,
you know,
all right,
I'm going to give you two compliments,
Sally.
You know,
like nice dress,
keep moving and keep it.
Hey Sally,
nice dress.
He's got to give him some better in there.
I'm not really good at this.
Okay.
Cause I feel like it's like a natural thing that you have.
It's all about,
you know what it is,
I think,
I think once you're secure with yourself and you're not feeling those feelings
of inadequacy,
that's when that's kind of natural swag can happen.
You can't manufacture it.
So that's why me trying to give him like lines to throw out sounds ridiculous
because they're completely manufactured.
Yeah.
And also you're a woman so you don't have to like hit on people.
You just show up,
look cute.
That's why we've been through this before.
I'm not getting into it again.
You're cute age.
Your opening line is,
hey Sally,
nice stress.
No,
that really wasn't terrible.
But,
but just to give out a compliment and keep it moving,
that's all him.
Can you come up with a middle ground between a hey Sally,
nice dress and hey Sally,
nice fucking rack.
Wah.
What I say,
I don't think that I can just make it something like,
you know,
just offhanded you know,
oh that's cool.
Or what's that?
Or did it or just ask about something about her.
You know,
what's that book you're reading?
What?
I'm trying to put it in context of like a school type of situation.
So it's not completely out of left field.
Good at starting the car getting in,
right.
Hey,
what's that book you're reading?
And then,
and then she's got to be like,
um,
uh,
fucking Harry Potter.
And then he like,
yeah,
saw that movie every very cool,
Oh God,
I'm the worst.
And then you face turns all red.
Well the thing about it is too is what we're talking about teenagers here.
So I don't know that this is,
this is fucking creepy.
Yeah.
We're a long ways away from being like and high school.
So I can't even like go back there mentally to figure out how a boy that age
would talk to him.
I have no idea cause I can't,
I can't remember anything previous to insult or a little bit like that.
That's how I always hit on negging.
Is that what it's called?
Yeah.
The old tearing them down building.
No,
not tearing them down but just giving him shit in a funny way.
Yeah.
Well that's all.
Yeah,
that can be cute for sure.
He is like a playful teasing.
Yeah.
But it's like you got to know the person well enough to do that.
You know what I mean?
It's like if it's some girl that he has and hasn't talked to and like three
years and all of a sudden he's like,
yeah,
we'll get blah,
blah,
blah and like she's going to be like,
what?
Who is that?
Yeah.
No,
that's the worst.
I've learned all these lessons.
It was that.
It's going to have to tell you.
It's less about,
here's my,
here's my final thought on it.
I think it's less about,
oh,
shut up.
I think it's less about how do I get the girls to like me?
Yeah,
it did.
Why did you tell him to shut up your face was was saying things?
No,
because no,
you're like,
well your face was saying to me,
so I told her to shut up.
I'm going to,
I'm going to tell you what my,
I was imitating a woman's face when I said something to her one time.
That was the face.
She made it me.
What do you mean?
What did you say?
Uh,
you know,
I was in between relationships.
I just spit it out.
No,
cause it's embarrassing.
I was in between relationships and all these comics were just like,
dude,
just,
you know,
just fucking say it and blah,
blah,
and just stay single and just bang a bunch of broads and blah,
blah.
So I tried to be that guy,
so,
and it was sort of working for me and then I just,
one night it just completely backfired.
I was at Dangerfield and this woman came up to me and told me how much she liked
my,
you know,
blah,
blah.
I started the small talk and everything and then I tried to be,
you know,
leather jacket guy said,
hey,
you want to just cut through the bullshit?
I mean,
I live right up the street from when it come.
She goes,
she just went like,
what?
Huh?
No,
no,
I,
and she slowly backed away and I was like,
I fucking,
it took me still at BB.
You blew it.
There was nothing to blow.
It was just fucking,
it wasn't even there.
There was no situation.
I completely,
I misread the whole thing.
I feel like this kid is,
it's got to get his,
his confidence and his own personal swag going.
That's all it is.
It's like,
I feel like it's not about the other people so much about how you feel about
yourself,
you know?
And I,
but I feel like that's also like a concept that's kind of hard for people that,
you know what,
dude?
You're going to figure it out.
Just keep fucking trying.
Say Hi.
Just say hi.
Hey.
How's it going?
And keep moving.
That's what I feel like.
You know how you're talking about the best way better than hey,
hi Sally.
Nice dress.
No,
that was the fucking worst advice ever.
You know,
judging by your skills and some of the shit that I said back in the day.
I don't know how we have a fucking mess I've made,
cause I think we're both
nerds.
All right.
Beat it.
I got to read the advertising and wrap this up.
I am,
but I got gotta.
I gotta do the advertising here.
stamps.com everybody.
Um,
wait a minute.
Did I already read this?
But I didn't.
I did read this.
Didn't I,
but then I didn't do he voice.
I didn't do any voice.
Oh Hey,
we want your business to make more money.
He voiced can help.
Here's how,
when your customers call you,
you'll have your own toll free number,
professional greeting,
dial by name directory,
and more.
You'll sound like a fortune 500 company and really stand out from your
competitors.
Eva Voice let's you find out,
oh shit,
he voice let's you give out one number that rings wherever you are.
You could even be at your kid's soccer game.
You'll never miss a chance to grow your business evolves even takes all your
voicemails,
transcribes them and sends them to you instantly as a text or email.
So you can check your voicemails before the meeting ends and not look rude.
He voice his only 13 bucks a month.
And right now my listeners can try he voice for free for 60 days.
That's right.
A 60 day free trial.
Don't put this off.
Turn down the radio,
get to a computer,
turn down the radio,
Jesus Christ.
Get to a computer and set up your evil ways.
60 Day free trial.
Now,
so you can see what I'm,
you can see what I mean.
See what I mean?
They're go to he voice.com Promo Code Bill,
Bravo,
India,
Lima,
Lima.
That's [inaudible] Dot Com Promo code bill and lastly,
but not leastly legal zoom.com every one.
If the excitement of starting your own business,
getting your first customer and finally quitting your job hasn't moved you to
action yet.
Here's another great reason to get started.
It's national.
Start Your business month again,
even in September and legal zoom wants to help you start your own corporation or
LLC or file your own DBA so you can get up and start running,
get the thing running or something like that quickly and easily.
Find out why more than 1 million entrepreneurs use legal zoom to start down the
path of successful business ownership this month only or next month or even the
following month as far as this copy goes.
Take advantage of their national starch,
your business month special and get a free three month trial of the all new
quickie books,
making it so much easier.
Run your new business.
That's $119 value for free.
When you enter [inaudible] in the referral box at checkout,
that's legalzoom.com promo code burr legal zoom provides self help services and
can connect you with the right attorney,
but they are not a law firm.
Legalzoom,
Promo Code Burr.
Okay,
this one's the last one.
I didn't realize I had another one.
Hulu plus everyone.
I love this thing.
Hulu plus.
Uh,
okay.
You've probably tried hulu.com who will plus it's so much more when Hulu plus
with Hulu plus you can watch your favorite shows anytime,
anywhere.
Hulu plus let you watch thousands of hit TV shows and movies in the living room
or on the go with your smartphone or tablet with Hulu.
Plus you can watch your favorite TV shows like SNL,
Jimmy Kimmel,
live shark tank and scandal.
Watch every episode of shows like lost law and order Svu,
doctor who and community.
You can also check out exclusive content including Hulu originals,
like the wrong mans and behind the mask.
Hulu new docu series that takes you inside the world of sports mascots.
That should say a Hulu.
Oh,
who lose new?
Why would I think they screwed up?
God knows it's always me.
You also get access to a collection of ad free movies and kids content.
All of this for only 799 a month.
Come on people catch up on current shows,
bid on old favorites or catch a great movie stream as many TV shows and movies
as you want,
wherever you want,
whatever you want right now,
you can try Hulu plus for free for Jay for two weeks.
When you go to Hulu plus.com/bill that's a special offer for my listeners.
Make sure you use Hulu plus.com/bill so you get that extended free trial and
that they also know that we sent you here.
Um,
we hear sent you there.
Jesus bill.
Go to Hulu plus.com/bill right now for your extended two weeks for free trial.
All right,
there you go.
Okay.
Here's a big dilemma for the week.
Everybody dilemma.
Dear Billy,
the baker's man,
big Fan,
first time writer,
oh first time to write dedicated listener for over three years.
I have an age old dilemma for you.
I had been engaged for about five months to the perfect woman for me about two
weeks ago.
She received a text after 10:00 PM from a male coworker.
Oh,
GG.
Like the mature man than I am.
I passed it off as nothing and kindly reminded her that text after 10:00 PM
should only be for emergencies or naughty talk between the two of us.
She agreed.
I work out of town five days a week.
Oh,
Jj age.
So I'm not there every night.
A few days ago she texted me that she's going to dinner with the same Galvao Jj.
What the fuck?
The same guy.
Just the two of them and they're going to the same restaurant as our first day.
Jesus Christ.
Dude,
I can't even read the rest of this text is so many flags flapping in my face.
I hope I'm not right.
She explained that they invited other coworkers,
but everyone declined or bailed.
Uh,
okay.
And if you did the same thing,
she would be cool with that.
I wouldn't be cool with this man or woman would not be cool with this.
This is not because I'm trying to see is this like a a female thing and a guy
doesn't understand.
This is not a cool,
this is not cool.
I tell her that this does not make me mad,
but I am not happy about it either.
She describes this guy is short single and dates around.
Yeah.
He's trying to bang her one more time before she gets married.
That's what he's doing.
I'm not saying that's what your fiances doing,
but that's what he's doing.
The fuck's he going there for conversation.
The guy dates around.
Um,
ever since that night and of course my dissatisfaction for the event that
occurred,
things had been slightly touchy between us.
I trust this girl,
but I could never trust a single guy.
I have.
I had issues with women and guy friends in the past.
My parents divorced when I was young duty,
infidelity and I'd never been 100% trusting of women.
Am I wrong to think that this is inappropriate for an engaged or married woman
to go out to dinner?
Let's face it,
it's a date with a single man or vice versa.
Oh yeah.
APPS,
a Fuckin lutely apps a Fuckin lutely.
Okay.
And the timing of this too,
where you're engaged and you're going to get married,
it's like,
okay.
Yeah,
I'd be like,
listen,
if you want out,
just say so.
Yeah.
Just rip the bandaid off.
Take my heart,
throw across the fucking ramen to the garbage disposal right now.
And let's just fucking get this over with because,
uh,
yeah,
dude,
that is a,
uh,
that,
that is not,
that is not cool.
That's not a cool situation.
MMM.
Yeah.
So I agree with you.
You haven't really asked me anything but I 100% agree with you.
That is not,
that's not cool.
That's a really shitty position for her to put you in a,
okay.
And I've been that piece of shit how the guy too,
so I know what his fucking attentions are.
So there you go.
There's that.
Um,
I don't know what to tell you.
That's one of those things where like you got to say,
you can't ever do that again.
But then there's also that thing like,
I shouldn't have to tell you not to do that.
Um,
and that's a hell of a fucking tail that they invited all of these other people
and they all declined.
That sounds like a really bad lie.
Um,
yeah.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
What does that expression about a woman's heart about the secrets it holds?
I shouldn't,
I shouldn't quote this because you'll never trust them.
MMM.
Who's getting,
oh,
you can't fucking trust anybody.
Let me look.
Let me just Google this woman's heart
secrets.
Let's see if it comes up.
Okay.
[inaudible] road.
Uh,
the woman's heart secrets.
No woman's heart program.
The woman's heart secret.
A woman's heart is a deep ocean of secrets.
There it is.
Then take too long.
Oh,
Holy Shit.
Unfucking believable.
That's amazing.
Is that true?
But you,
you know,
this way never believe in stereotypes because they always say women can never
shut the fuck up.
They can't keep a secret and they're always gossiping.
Maybe they keep their secrets.
Maybe I should shut the fuck up.
And I've said,
enough dump.
Thanks for the week.
What do you think?
I think so.
Enjoy the rest of your Labor Day.
All right.
That's the podcast for this week.
God bless Alia.
Thank you to everybody.
Came out to the,
I'm the odd ball tour.
Thanks for everybody who tweeted that they liked me.
Thank you.
Even more than people said they didn't like me.
Uh,
they were fucking hilarious.
And,
uh,
that's it.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you next week.